So just a brief
announcement, on this Friday
you guys have a
writing tutorial.
It's at 2 p.m.
there's only one tutorial
this week at 2 p.m.,
and it's going to
be in this room.
So make sure you come.
We're going to talk about
issues involved with preparing
and presenting your DP2.
And it's really important that
you come to pay attention.
So today we're going to continue
our discussion of networking
and network layering.
If you remember
last time, we talked
about the three layers that are
in any typical network stack.
And these three layers we said
were the end-to-end layer,
the network layer,
and the link layer.
And we went to the example of
how these three layers interact
with each other as,
say, a message is
sent through a network.
So, on a typical sender node,
we said there are these three
layers --
And there might also
be a receiver node.
And then there could be several.
Each time a message is
sent through the network,
it might pass through any number
of intermediate gateway nodes,
or intermediate switches.
So when a packet
gets sent in, it
gets sent through
the end-to-end layer
in through the network layer,
down into the link layer.
The link layer
chooses the next link
to send the packet
out over, since it's
one of these switches.
The switch looks at the packet,
sends it up to its own network
layer, which is in charge
of determining the next link
that the message will take.
On the next hop, the message
goes up to the link layer.
The link layer determines
yet another link
for the message to take.
The network layer determines
yet another message, link,
for the message to take.
And then finally,
the message reaches
the receiver or the message
propagates up through the link
layer into the network
layer, and then
finally to the end-to-end
layer, and out to the user.
So we talked a
little bit last time
about various things that
happen in this architecture.
We said that there's this
process of encapsulation
that happens at each
step along the way.
So the end-to-end layer
may attach headers
on to the packet, a header
or trailer onto the packet;
the network layer may
attach a header and trailer,
and the link layer may
attach a header and trailer.
But at no point does any
layer look at the data
that a higher layer sent.
And you also notice that in
this architecture, what we've
shown here is that only the
link layer and the network
layer of the switches that
are forwarding packets
are actually
processing the packets.
So the end-to-end
layer, by definition,
is not involved in the
forwarding of the packet.
The end-to-end layer
is only involved
when one of the endpoints of
the communication is involved.
So what we're going
to talk about today,
we're going to finish very
briefly our discussion
of the link layer.
And then we're going to
turn and focused mostly
on the networking layer.
So do you remember last time?
We got as far as saying
that the link layer is
in charge of a number of
sort of important issues
with the transmission of data
across one link of the network.
And we talked for awhile
at the end of class
last time about this
analog, to digital,
sorry, got that backwards
digital to analog
to digital conversion.
We are going to talk
about the other issue,
though, that I said
we needed to talk
about in the context
of the network layer
or the link layer is
the issue of framing.
So the idea with framing is when
you're sending a message out
over a network link, the
receiver on the other end
needs to have some
way of knowing
that a packet is starting or
a packet is ending, right?
So as we call these
packets when they
are at the link layer, frames.
So, the issue with framing is to
identify the sort of beginning
and end of every
one of these frames
as it transmits
over the network.
And there is a sort
of fairly obvious way
to do this is, well,
attach some special symbol,
but some special
symbol at the beginning
and end of every packet.
So, for example, if we
were looking at Ethernet,
the payload of an
Ethernet packet
might contain the
destination address,
the source address, the type.
So we'll talk more about
what the type field means
in a minute, the data, and
some checksum information that
can be used to detect errors.
And the preamble
is a special code
that is attached
to the beginning
of every one of these messages.
And this is used to make the
Manchester encoding, which
you remember we talked
about last class.
This is used, sorry,
to allow the phase lock
loop to lock into the
message, which we talked about
at last class.
And it might be, in
the case of Ethernet,
it's a well-defined sequence:
one, zero, one, zero, one,
zero, one, zero.
But remember that
with Manchester
encoding that the data
that's actually transmitted
looks a little bit different.
And then following
the preamble, there
is this start of frame symbol.
And then at the
end of the message,
there's this end symbol.
So, one thing we might
be concerned about
is, say, for example
what if the network
layer tries to
send a message that
contains the end symbol in it?
that would be a problem,
right, because then the end
layer would have inadvertently
terminated the message,
even though this wasn't
really the end of the message,
this is just something
that happened
to be the same code as whatever
the link layer had chosen
for its end of code symbol.
And the reason that this
is a concern is, remember,
we don't want the
network layer to have
to understand lots of details
about how the link layer
operates underneath it, right?
The network layer shouldn't
have to make any assumptions
about what our valid
symbols for it to transmit,
and what are invalid
symbols for it to transmit.
So the way that we're
going to solve this
is through one of
two techniques.
One: so the first technique
that will talk about
for a moment is this
idea of bit stuffing.
I'll get to that in a minute.
Another simple thing
that we could do
would be to simply use a
code that can't possibly
be generated by, say for
example, the Manchester
encoding scheme.
So if the network layer sends
a message like one, one, one,
one, the link layer is
going to convert that
into some sequence
of ones and zeros
once it applies
Manchester coding.
So if the link layer
on the receiver
sees a message like
one, one, one, one, one,
that can't possibly
be a valid code.
That can't possibly
be a valid message
that could have been generated
by the network layer.
Only the link layer can actually
send that sequence of bits out.
So we could tell that would
be a terminating symbol.
Another simple way, though,
to send one of these end codes
is using this technique
called bit stuffing.
And the idea is pretty
simple, and it's
kind of a neat technique that
can be used in general when
you have to do this kind
of encoding a lower layer.
So the idea is,
suppose we set our end
code was equal to some bit
string like one, one, one, one.
And, the solution in bit
stuffing is very simple.
What it says is that when you
receive a sequence of bytes
or sequence of bits from the
network layer at the link
layer, it says that you should
convert any sequence of bytes
that look like one, one,
one, three ones in a row,
into three ones in a
row followed by a zero.
So this happens at the center.
And then the receiver
just reverses this,
says any sequence of one,
one, one, zero, gets converted
to one, one, one, one.
OK, so you could
see that this means,
and this transform
is only applied
to the payload of
data packets that it's
coming from the network layer
down into the link layer.
OK, so you can see that there
is no way for the link layer,
now, to send a sequence,
or for the network layer
to actually cause
four one's in a row
to be sent out over the wire
because of this transformation.
So if the network layer
tries to send a message that
contains a sequence with four
ones, what the link layer is
going to send is
three ones followed
by a zero followed by a one.
Notice, however,
that this also means
that if the network layer tries
to send a sequence of three
ones followed by a zero, the
link layer will transmit three
ones followed by two zeros, OK?
And then at the
receiving end, we
can just trivially apply
this reverse transformation.
So this idea of
bit stuffing allows
us to guarantee that
any time that the link
layer on the receiving
side actually
sees four ones in a row, this
is really the end symbol as
opposed to the network
layer trying to transmit
four ones in a row, OK?
So that's all I want to
say about the network layer
or about the link layer.
And what I want to
do now is to move
on to a discussion
of the network layer.
So the network layer --
-- has two primary functions
that we're going to talk about
today.
The first was forwarding.
And the second is routing.
So the idea was
forwarding is as follows.
forwarding is basically
to allow nodes to decide,
given a particular packet
to allow them to decide what
the next hop for that packet
should be by looking at
the destination address
deaths in the message that
they are trying to transmit.
So they're going to look
at the destination address
and make some decision about
where to send this packet next.
And they're going to
do that by keeping
a table that basically
maps every address
into the next link to send to.
So let's look at a
really simple example.
Suppose we have five
machines, A, B, C, D, and E --
-- connected as follows.
And let's number these links.
Let's number this
link from E to B.
We're going to call it L1.
We're going to letter
this link E to D L2.
And then, I'm going to
number all the links sort
of in the same way.
So, B's link to A.
I'll number L1.
B's link to D I'll number
L2, and B's link to E I'll
number L3.
So, notice that this link, I've
given two names to this link
depending on whether
we're talking about it
from a perspective of B or E.
OK, so now we can do
the same numbering
for all of the other links.
So, call this L1.
Call this L2.
Call this L3.
And, this one is L1, L2
from C's perspective.
And this is L1 and L2
from A's perspective.
So now we have this
labeled graph here.
And now let's look and see what
the forwarding table for one
of these nodes might look like.
So, for example, if we
look at the forwarding
table for node A,
what we'll see is
one entry for each of the other
nodes that are in the network.
And this entry will tell
us, given a message destined
for this, whatever address is
in, this is the destination
address.
So given a particular
destination address,
it will tell us what the
next link we should use is.
OK so, and this is
the forwarding table
for a particular node.
So in this case, we're
looking at the forwarding
table for node A.
So, if A sees a node destined
to node A, what should
it do with it?
Well, it's destined
to its local mode.
So it's going to do the obvious
thing, which is send it up
to the end to end layer.
So I'll just write E to E.
So if it receives a node
destined for B, it's going to,
presumably it wants to send
it along whatever the shortest
path is.
And we'll talk about how the
next step, routing is actually
deciding which thing
should be there.
But, for example, it might
have L2 as the next link.
OK, and if it
wants to send to C,
it might have L1
as the next link.
So, A to B is using, it's using
L2, and A to C it's using L1.
OK, now, node D is, say
if it wants to route to D,
it's going to have to route
through either B or C.
And so, for now, let's
just say it routes to L1.
And so, it routes
to C, and then it's
going to allow C to go ahead
and forward the packet onto D.
If it wants to route
to E, well, again, it
can either route
through B or through C.
But let's say maybe it
wants to route through B
because it has a shorter path.
So, we'll write L2 here.
OK, so this is just a
very simple example.
Now you can see that any time
that A wants to send a packet,
it has a next hop that it
should use for every destination
address within the network.
So, this is very simple.
And this is sort of a high level
the way that forwarding works.
Of course, there are
some other details
associated with getting
forwarding to work properly.
In order to sort of talk about
how forwarding actually works,
the interaction between these
layers, what I want to do
is just give you some examples
of what the packet headers look
like for different
kinds of protocols that
are used in the real world.
So we're talking about here,
this is the IPV4 header.
So, remember, IP is a protocol
that runs at the network layer.
And this header has the
following information in it.
So, what I've shown
here down the left side
is a sequence of words.
So these are 32-bit words.
And I'd just broken up the
bits by number along the top.
So, the first sort of
word has information
about the version of the
protocol that's running in it.
So in this case the
version would be four
because this is IPV4.
There's a new IP
protocol that is
in the process of
being deployed called
IPV6, which you'll
sometimes see referenced.
There's a header length field.
It just specifies the
length of the header.
There's a TOS field.
This is type of service.
It's typically not
used in most packets.
And then there's
the packet length
which is the entire length
of the whole packet,
not just the length
of the header.
So this should be
fairly straightforward
except for the type
of service field
which you guys don't need
to pay any attention to.
So the next field, so
there's this identification.
The next [word?] has
identification, flags,
and fragment offset.
Let's just look at the next one.
And the next one has
time delay of end
to end protocol and checksum.
So the important
fields, I'm blanking
on what the identification
field contains,
which is why I'm stalling.
So the identification
field, so let's
just talk about the
other fields and we'll
come back to identification
if I remember it.
So the flag's field simply
contains some information
about whether this packet
has been fragmented
or should be fragmented.
So fragmentation is something
that this packet can be split
into multiple sub packets.
You don't need to worry
about it too much.
And the fragment offset
as if this packet has
been split into these sub
packets, these fragments.
Then this is the number
of the fragment that's
being transmitted so,
the interesting ones
now come in this next row.
So, we have the
time to live flag,
the end to end protocol,
and then the checksum.
So, the time to live field
is sometimes abbreviated TTL.
And time to live is a little
bit of a strange name for it.
Basically what this says is
that as this packet is being
forwarded through
the network, we're
going to decrement the time
to live by one on every step
that it's forwarded
through the network.
And if the time to
live reaches zero,
we're going to stop
forwarding this.
So the reason that we
care about time to live
is that there can sometimes be
loops and are fording routes.
So suppose that
we had set this up
so that A sends messages
destined for, say, A sent
messages destined
for E through C.
But C sent messages destined
through E through A, right?
So that would be a loop,
and that would be a problem.
So, we're going to try and
avoid forming these loops
when we do our routing protocol.
But they're going to be
certain situations when
those fail, for example, that
loops can occasionally occur.
And we're going to use
the time to live field
to eliminate those.
The next thing is the
end to end protocol.
So the end to end protocol
is the specification
of which end to end
protocol we should
forward this message onto.
So I'll talk about
that more in a second.
And then there's
this checksum field,
which can be used to determine
whether the message was fully
formed, although it turns
out that in most cases in IP,
this field probably isn't used.
So, and then there
is the source address
and a destination address.
So these are IP
addresses that identify
the endpoints of the packet
and then, finally, there
is some additional,
optional information
which can specify a huge
range of different things.
It can be up to 44 bytes.
In this case, you don't
need to worry about it.
And then finally
there's the payload,
which is the actual message
that was sent from the end
to end layer into the IP layer.
So what you see
happening here, if we
look at a diagram of what
the interface between the end
to end layer, what the interface
between the network layer
and link layer is.
So let's just look at
our three layers again.
We have our end to end layer.
We have our network layer.
And we have our link layer.
And one of the things
that we can pick out here
is that notice that
we have this end
to end protocol that's
actually in our IP packet
so what this means is that if I
have a network protocol like IP
that's running here, when it
receives a packet destined
for its local address, say,
destined to itself where it's
supposed to forward it up
to the end to end layer,
it can actually dispatch
this packet to a number
of different end to end layers.
So, for example, we talked last
time about the TCP protocol.
But there are a
number of other end
to end layers that can
be used in the Internet.
So we'll talk in this
class a little bit
about a different
protocol called UDP.
We'll talk about this more.
We'll talk about the end to
end layer more next time.
But the point is that this
up call to the layer above us
is controlled by the contents
of this header that we have.
So similarly, if we look
an Ethernet header, what
the Ethernet header has on it is
the destination address, which
is 48 bits, and the source
address which are 48 bits,
followed by a link protocol.
So the link protocol says,
and so the Ethernet, remember,
is a link layer protocol.
And what happens is, so
if we have Ethernet here,
it has a protocol ID that
specifies the protocol
that it's supposed to
send messages back up to.
OK, so these fields, one
question you might ask
is, well, how does the Ethernet
layer know which link protocol
it should send messages to?
Or how does the network protocol
know which end to end protocol
to send its messages to?
So it's kind of
interesting and it's worth
looking at the pseudocode
for one of these protocols
just quickly in
order to understand
this a little bit better.
So let's look at the
pseudocode for the function
which we're going to call Net
Handle that accepts messages
either from the end to
end layer to be sent out
across the network,
or from the link layer
when a message is
sort of received
as it's forwarded through.
So we can use this procedure
both for down calls
and up calls, and
it accepts a packet
which, say for example, has this
format that I've shown here,
which is the same as
the format that I've
shown on the other page.
So the first thing
this is going to do
is it's going to check
and see if the destination
of the packet, for example,
is the local address.
And if the destination of the
packet is the local address,
then we know what we
should do with it, right?
We're going to pass it
up to the end and layer.
And we're going to send,
so what we're going to do
is we're going to de-encapsulate
this packet, right?
We are going to strip
the header off of it.
So we're just going to send the
payload up to the layer above,
but we're going to
need to dispatch
to the appropriate
layer, which we're
going to do by sort
of saying and naming
what the end to end protocol is
that we would like to dispatch
to.
And there may be
some other options
that we pass along
with this as well.
So that's what the
three dots there mean.
So now, if this isn't
for the local packet,
for the local node, then we need
to send this packet out again,
right?
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to check the time
to live on this packet.
And if the time to live
is greater than zero,
then we are going to
decrement the time to live.
If the time to live is
less than or equal to zero,
then we know that we're not
going to forward this packet
anymore.
We're just going to drop it.
So the time to live
gets set initially
by the first guy who
sends the packet out.
He initializes it
to some value, which
is the maximum number of hops
that he wants this message
to be propagated for.
And so, after we decrement
the time to live,
we're going to look up
in our forwarding table
the next link that
we want to use.
OK, and what I've shown
here is that we're
going to look up
the sort of protocol
to use and the name
of the next link.
So, for example,
this IP layer might
have Ethernet underneath it,
which might be one protocol.
But there might
also be a WiFi layer
that's here that we could
also send messages out.
So we could send out through
either one of these protocols.
So we look up the one
we want to send out,
and then we call this
link send routine,
which actually does
the transmission out
over the appropriate named link.
Notice now what I've specified,
I have this [NETPROT?] in all
caps here.
So in this case, this
should be, for example, IP.
It's the name of the
network protocol.
So when the network protocol
sends the message to the link
layer below it, it specifies
what the network protocol
is that wants to have
returned, that it
wants to be called on return.
So it says, please
link layer; when
you have received a message
that needs to be sent up
to the network layer, dispatch
it to the network layer named
NETPROT.
OK, and then for
example the TTL we
can't transmit the message out.
TTL has expired.
If we've sent it too
many hops already,
then we're going to need to do
some kind of error handling.
In this case, error handling
might be, send a message back
to the source address
of this message,
and tell them that the TTL
ran out on this message.
That will be one
thing you could do.
Another thing you might do
is simply drop the packet
or ignore the error.
OK, so this is just
a simple example
of how forwarding might work.
And what I wanted to
use it to illustrate
is the fact that there can
be multiple different link
layers at the bottom that
can be dispatched to.
And these link
layers can, in fact,
dispatch up to multiple
different network layers
as well.
So in today's Internet,
it's uncommon to see,
you'll rarely
interact with anything
that's not using IP at some
layer or some network layer.
But there have,
in the past, been
a variety of different network
layers that have been proposed.
You guys may have
seen an old protocol
from Novell called
IPX, or you may
have used AppleTalk, which
is an Apple protocol that
in some varieties also
runs at the IP layer.
Finally, I just
want to point out
that the last little layering
detail that I want to get to
is that if you think
about the link layer
from the perspective
of the network layer,
the link layer is
simply, the link
just looks like one hop
to one more connection.
But in fact, these links
can, themselves, be networks.
So it's just kind of
a weird statement.
But here's a simple
example of what I mean.
Suppose that this link
layer, that one of the link
layers that the IP layers
can send a message to
is a modem connection, OK?
But if you think about
what a modem connection is,
right, it's a connection
out over a phone line.
And a phone line
is, itself, right,
as we talked about at
the beginning of class,
a phone line is, itself,
a kind of the network.
Right, it's this kind of
circuit-switched thing
that goes through multiple
ones of these circuit
switches as opposed to
going through these.
So underneath the
modem, the modem layer,
which looks like a link
to the network layer,
there's actually, these link
layers can actually themselves
be composed of a
number of links,
and they can, themselves,
be a type of a network.
So it's sort of worth
realizing that there
is a kind of hierarchical
relationship, one,
but the link layer
may actually itself
be a network consisting
of multiple links,
but from the point of view of
the higher-level link layer
here, it's just a single
link, a modem connection
to some endpoint that we
can send a message over.
OK, so what I want to do
now is take you through,
we're going to switch
gears a little bit
and talk about the
sort of next piece
that I said we
needed to address,
which is this issue of routing.
So I said we're going to
talk about forwarding,
and then we're going to talk
about something else called
routing.
So routing is the process
by which we build up
our forwarding tables.
OK, so what I showed
you here was I
just sort of told
you what the values
that should go in these
forwarding tables should be.
But I didn't tell you
how they were derived
or where they came from.
So in this case of
the simple network,
it was relatively easy
for us to, by hand,
sort of come up with a set
of possible forwarding paths
that seem reasonable.
But you can imagine that if
this network had scaled up
to a million nodes,
that's not something
that we want any
individual to have to do.
No person should
have to configure
all these routing tables or
all these forwarding tables.
So instead, what
we're going to do
is we're going to use
this process called
routing in order to
build these forwarding
tables automatically.
And we really want our routing
protocol to be three things.
First, we wanted to be scalable.
And the obvious way in which
we want it to be scalable
is the way that I just said.
We don't want to
have to have people,
we want this thing
to scale up to, say,
a million nodes or
several million nodes
and be able to continue to work.
We shouldn't have to have
people sort of involved
with configuring, building
up these forwarding tables
at every step of the way.
We also want it to be robust.
So by that, I mean it should
be tolerant of faults.
If a node fails in the
network, the network
should eventually discover
that that node has failed
and be able to forward
packets around the failure
or be able to compensate for
the failure if at all possible.
Finally, we want
this routing protocol
hopefully to be distributed.
So we don't want to have
to have one machine that's
responsible for setting up
the forwarding table on all
the other machines.
We don't want to
have one machine that
needs to contact all
of the other nodes
and collect information about
what all of their links are,
and assemble all of those
links together into one
global forwarding scheme.
And this really gets at
the scalability again.
So what I want to
do is to take you
through the process of routing.
Before I do that, I just want
to take a quick digression.
We're going to start off with
very tiny networks on this,
and just talking about a
very simple baby network.
It just so that
you guys don't feel
like this is
completely unrealistic,
I want to show you that in
fact the Internet at some level
started out like this, too.
What we're going to do it
in the course of this class
is sort of build up from these
very simple networks that maybe
look the way the Internet did
at first, the schemes that
are more like what is actually
used in today's production
Internet.
So, sorry I went
back on you guys.
OK, so this is a picture of what
the Internet look like in 1969.
So you may not be able to read
the labels on these things,
but we're looking
at three nodes here.
This is UC Santa Barbara
on the coast of California.
It's southern
central California.
This is Stanford
Research Institute, SRI,
which is the Bay Area.
This is Utah, and this is UCLA.
So, this was the ARPANET,
which was a precursor
to the Internet, and was
sort of one of the very first
of these large
wide-area networks
that was ever developed.
And each of these
little square nodes
here is a machine
that's on this.
So there were four machines
on the ARPANET in 1969.
And there were these four
routers that were being used.
So, this is 1971.
So by 1971, there
still is a cluster
of these machines in California.
But you notice that Illinois,
Carnegie Mellon, and Boston
have suddenly
appeared on this map.
So, MIT is here,
Lincoln Labs is here,
Harvard is here, BBN, which
is another large company that
does a lot of networking
research in this area is here.
So, the network has
started to evolve.
And in particular, you
notice that there are now
these sort of two clusters,
these two regions, one
on the West Coast and
one on the East Coast
that have a number of nodes.
So, it just keeps
growing and growing.
So, by 1980, you
see the network has
gotten substantially larger.
And one of the interesting
things about this
is you are starting to
see a diversity of links.
So notice that Hawaii is now
connected into California
by way of a satellite
connection, as is London.
So, we now have not only just
these wires that are running,
but in fact we have
wireless links.
But at the same time
this was happening,
all the protocols we've
been talking about
were being developed.
And one of the
whole goals of this
was to be able to support
these multiple different kinds
of links on top of the
standard networking protocol.
OK, so by 1987, this
thing has really
become, turned into a number
of decentralized networks.
There's this large network
called the ARPANET.
There is something smaller
called the NSF backbone,
and a number of other
networks that are
military networks, and so on.
These are all
connected together,
and they're all
being, by 1987 they
were all running this
TCP/IP protocol that
was being used to exchange
information between all
of these things.
So roundabout a few
years after this, right,
the sort of World Wide
Web suddenly happened,
and there became this
huge commercial interest
in the Internet.
And that has really just
sparked this explosion of nodes,
and made the network just
huge and incredibly vast.
So it's hard to see this,
but in the middle of this
you notice that there is
a little orange node here.
This bar on the left side
is showing the out degree
of the nodes in the network.
So this number is 2,977.
So that means there's a node at
the center of the Internet that
has 2,977 links to
other nodes in it.
OK, so this is a really
incredibly large network.
And you notice that
all of these 20 or 30
bright pink red nodes
here have hundreds
to thousands of
outgoing connections
on each one of them.
So there is this
core of the Internet
that is very highly
connected to a very
large part of the network.
And now, down or
out around the edges
are these much
smaller networks that
have much lower collectivity.
And these are things
like service providers,
for example, that consumers
might pay some money
to get a connection from.
So this is the sort of
core of the Internet.
These are the people who are
not so much the end-users
on the Internet, but
the service providers
that are providing
connectivity for the end-users.
Each one of these
little nodes represents
one of those service providers.
This was as of 2003.
OK, so what I want to do
now is to start as I said.
We're going to sort of
start off with a baby
version of a network.
In particular, we're going
to look how forwarding,
or how routing might work
in this very simple network
that I've shown here.
So let's see what happens.
So we're going to use
a protocol that we
call path vector routing.
And the idea behind
path vector routing
is that we're going to build
up the paths from, that is,
the sequence of nodes that we
should forward messages through
in order to reach a
particular destination.
And the way this
is going to work
is we're going to
have two steps.
So, let's put it over here.
So routing is going to consist
of two steps: an advertisement
phase or an advertisement
step, and an integration step.
And the idea is that during
the advertisement step,
each node is going to
advertise what other
nodes it knows how to reach.
And then during the
integration step,
each node is going to take
all of the advertisements that
heard during the previous
advertisement step,
and integrate them into
a new set of routes
that identifies the new set of
nodes that this node can reach.
OK, so this'll be very clear
when I show you the example.
So let's just look at the
case of all the nodes,
figuring out how they
can reach node E.
So what's going to happen
is that first node E
is going to send out
an advertisement that
says that node E knows how
to reach node E, right,
which it obviously does.
And the way that
it reaches node E
is simply by
forwarding a message up
to its end to end layer.
So it says, to reach
node E, come this way.
And it sends it out
over the two links
that it has to node C and D.
So when node C and D
hear this advertisement,
during this integration step
what they are going to do
is to add this information
about this connection to node E,
and they're going to store
which link it is that they
send that message out over.
They should send messages out
over in order to reach node E.
So node C is going
to store link one,
and node D is going
to store link two.
But in addition to
that link, they're
going to store the
path that they use.
But now what's going to happen
is that each of C and D,
during the next
advertisement step,
C and D are going to also
advertise the information
that they have about
the nodes that they
can reach in the network.
So, I'm only showing the
advertisements for node E here.
But of course, at the
same time, C and D
are also advertising
the fact that they
can reach themselves,
and maybe their ability
to reach other nodes in the
network that we haven't shown.
So we're just looking
at E, but bear in mind
that all the advertisements
are being done for all
the nodes at the same time.
So, C sends out an advertisement
that says I can reach node E,
and the way to do it
is to send, and I can
reach node E via C and then E.
And similarly, D
sends out a message
that says I can reach
node E by a D and then E.
So, OK, up to this
point we haven't really
seen anything very interesting.
But now during the
next integration step,
we see that these
two nodes, B and A,
now have heard an advertisement
that gives them a path that
allows them to reach node E.
So now, every node
has a path that
allows them to reach node E.
But this advertisement
and integrations process
is going to keep going on.
So, for example,
nodes A and B are
going to advertise that
they can, also, reach
node E to their neighbors.
And in this case, it's probably
unlikely that any of the nodes
would like to switch
to a new route.
So, for example, it's not clear,
there's no reason, for example,
that A would want to
forward its message.
It's probably
unlikely that A will
want to forward its messages
through B to reach E,
right, because that's going
to be a longer path than for A
to send its messages simply
through C and then to E.
But B doesn't actually
know whether or not
A knows about E yet or not.
So it needs to continue to
broadcast this information out.
So this is pretty simple.
It's pretty clear
how this works.
And once this process has
been running for a while,
you can see that the network is
going to converge into a state
where every node has, as long
as the network is connected,
it will converge into a state
where every node has a path
to node E, right?
And the amount of time that
it'll take for that to happen
is equal to the
maximum number of hops
that any node is
away from node E.
So, once this node
has converged,
now we can trivially build up
our forwarding table simply
by pulling out the link number
from each one of these nodes.
So, for example, we can see
that E's forwarding table simply
says: to reach node E, you
send it to my end to end layer.
D's forwarding table would
say, to reach node E,
you send it over my link, L2.
C's forwarding table would
say, to reach node E,
you send it over L1.
B's forwarding table would
say, to reach node E,
you send it out over
my L1, and so on, OK?
So, once we've done this
path vector routing,
at the end of this process
we will know which links,
we'll have built up
the forwarding table
that we can use for
sending our links.
OK, so this is a
very simple process.
But now, let's look
at what happens
when something, so
what we said here
is that each advertisement step,
and after each advertisement,
we're going to go ahead
and do integration.
Integration, basically
what we're going to do
is we're going to try and pick
the best path in some way.
What we've shown here
is just simply picking
the shortest path.
So we've picked the
shortest possible path
for every node to reach node E.
And in case it wasn't
clear, I didn't explicitly
state this, it's important to
realize that nodes are going
to ignore advertisements
with their own address
in the vector.
OK so if, for example, when
node E hears node D advertising
that it can reach node E,
node E is going to say,
oh, well, I am node E.
I don't actually need
to pick up this path.
I don't need to send my packets
to myself through node D.
That would be a
silly thing to do.
That would create
a routing loop,
which is something that we
presumably don't want to do.
So, this is a simple
way using these path
vectors we can use to avoid
creating routing loops.
OK, so now let's look at
what happens, something
a little bit more interesting.
Let's look and see what happens
when, for example, there's
a failure.
So this is just exactly the
same network that I showed you.
But, suppose for example that
the link between D and E fails.
OK, so now node D no longer
has a route to node E.
But remember, the
way that I described
this is that this
advertisement process is just
going to continue going on
in the background, right?
So what's going to happen
is that at some point node
D is going to realize that
its link to node E went down.
And, node D is going to cross
this table out of its entry.
So, node D is going to basically
stop hearing advertisements
from node E.
When it stops hearing
advertisements from node E,
eventually it's going
to do something.
It's basically going to expire
that entry from its link table.
So after it hasn't
heard advertisements
from node E for a while,
it'll expire that entry.
And then, sometime later it
will hear an advertisement
from node C saying I know
how to get to node E.
And now, node D can go ahead
and integrate this new path
into its routing table.
Now, notice that
this process is just
going to propagate
through the network.
So, once node D stops
hearing advertisements
for how to reach
node E, it's going
to stop sending advertisements
for how to reach node E.
And so, similarly, because B
is also routing its information
through, had previously
been routing its packets
to reach node E
by way of D, it's
going to say, oh, well, I stop
hearing about this route, DE,
from node D.
So I'm going to stop using this.
And instead, then
sometime later, it's
going to hear about
this new route, DCE,
and it's going to integrate
that into its table.
So, it's this
process where there
is this sort of process whereby
nodes continually advertise
and integrate routes.
And there's this sort of
interesting thing which
happens, which is that nodes
forget about routes that they
haven't heard about
for awhile when
they miss an advertisement.
So this, forgetting about
routes is an important sort
of principle that's often
employed in networking
called soft state.
And the idea with soft state
is that you should only
keep information when that
information gets refreshed.
So all the information that you
have has some time limit on it.
And when you haven't
heard that information
refreshed after some time
limit, you throw it out.
So that's what we're doing
with the routes here.
And so we only keep
routes that we have heard
advertised recently, basically.
And that has this
nice property that it
allows us to adapt to faults
within the network, right?
So we saw a failure happen.
We saw that sometime
after that failure,
this soft state
property would cause
the information about
the link between D and E
to disappear from the
network, and then nodes
would rediscover their
new links that allow
them to connect to node E.
OK, so what I want
to do now, so this
is sort of the basic process.
And, path vector routing is
fairly similar to the way
that routing in the
Internet actually works.
For next time in
recitation, you're
going to talk about a protocol
called the border gateway
protocol.
And you're going to actually
study in much more detail
how Internet routing works.
But this is a nice simple
model of how routing
in a small network might act.
So the problem with what
we've discussed so far,
while we are here, is that if
this is a very large network,
these number of
routes that you're
going to have to hear
about is really huge.
So suppose that this, instead
of being a five node network
was a million node network.
Well, now every node is
going to have a table that's
a million entries long, right?
That's going to be
really big, and it's
going to have to hear a
million advertisements.
And every time there's
a failure, well,
that's going to be
a pain because we're
going to have to wait for that
information about that failure
to propagate through
the whole network.
So in some sense, this simple
path vector routing protocol
we have doesn't really
meet the scalability goal
that we want to
scale this network up
to a very large size.
So we have an issue
with path vector routing
and its scalability.
OK, so the solution is
a solution that is often
used when we have a scalability
problem in a computer system:
its hierarchy, OK?
So let's see what
I mean by that.
So, you remember when I
was showing those pictures
of the Internet, there are these
different kind of subnetworks
that were forming over
time on the West Coast,
on the East Coast, or there was
the ARPANET, and the NSFNET,
and the MILNET [SP?] that
were these sort of different
networks that were all a part
of the Internet as a whole.
But they were these sort
of different regions
that were separately
administered,
and that often corresponded
to a specific organization
like the NSF or
like the military.
So, oftentimes these
regions, so it's
very common when you
look at any network
to have these kinds
of regions in them.
So, for example, clearly
there's a network
that is MIT's network, right?
And Harvard, for example,
has a network that's
Harvard's network, right?
And those two things are
sort of logical regions
that define different
parts or different groups
within a network.
So if you were to
look at any network,
you would see that sort of
almost any large network
is organized in this
way into these regions.
In the paper next
time, we're going
to call these regions
autonomous systems or AS's, OK,
so autonomous as in sort
of operating on its own,
operating without
being dependent
on the other parts
of the system.
So for example, if MIT's
Internet connection went down,
connection to the
outside world went down,
that wouldn't stop you
from being able to connect
to machines within MIT, right?
So MIT is autonomous
in the sense
that it continues to operate in
the absence of its connection
to the rest of the Internet.
So let's look at a simple
example of a network that
has this hierarchy
property, and see
how we would modify the
routing algorithm that I just
talked about.
So suppose I have
two small networks,
each with three nodes in them.
Let's call them A, B,
C, and D, E, and F, OK?
So, these are each
going to be autonomous
systems, which I'll draw by
drawing a circle around them.
OK, so one way we
could be routing
would be to do what
I had shown before,
which is that each node
within, say, this autonomous
region which I'll label
one, or autonomous system
one, and this one two,
would have information
about all the other nodes
everywhere else in the network.
But that has the scalability
problem that we mentioned.
So instead, what
we want to do is
we want to make it so that only
a few of the nodes in here,
so that we don't have
to have information
about all of the nodes that are
anywhere within the network.
We only have to know
about a few nodes
we say are on the edge of
each one of these networks.
So the idea is as follows.
Suppose these are
connected in this way.
And what we're
going to do is we're
going to appoint one node within
each one of these regions.
For example, it could
be several modes.
One of these regions to
be a so-called border
node that sort of sits on the
edge of these two regions.
And we're going to connect
just those two nodes together.
So we're only going to have a
small number of links between
our two AS's.
And now, if we look at the
forwarding table for one
of these nodes within, say, AS1,
it's going to look as follows.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to write the addresses
for these different AS's
as hierarchical addresses.
So, we're going to call
node A's address 1.A.
And, we'll call node
E's address 2.E, OK?
So, what our forwarding
table looks like
is a list of addresses,
and then a link to use.
OK, so this is going to be
the forwarding table, again,
for node A.
So, A is going to
have an address.
It's going to have
an address 1.A in it.
And, the link to use, in
that case, we've already said
is end-to-end.
OK, it's going to have an
address 1.B. So, to get to B,
A is going to route
by this link here,
which let's call this
link number one, OK?
So, it's going to
route to link one.
And it's going to have a
connection to 1.C, which
is going to route
via this link here,
which let's label that two, OK?
So now, we don't
have any information
about how to reach network two.
So what we're going to do is
rather than storing information
about every machine
and network two,
we're going to store just
information about how
to reach the edge
of network two,
and then trust that network two
is going to be able to route
to anybody whose
address begins with two.
So what we're going to do is
we're going to say two dot
star, right, two dot everybody.
So, [we'll star?] the character
that says anybody whose address
has this prefix two dot.
So, anybody whose
address has prefix two
dot, we are just going
to send to node C.
So, we're just going to
send that over link two, OK?
And so, similarly
on the other side,
we're going to have a table.
Each of these nodes is going
to have an entry, one dot star,
that specifies that it should
route messages for network one
through node D.
OK, so you see in
this way now what
we've been able to
do is to make it
so that each one of these
autonomous systems, sort
of each node only knows
how to route to other nodes
within its sort of group, and
that in order to cross groups,
you route through one of these
special sort of border routers
or border nodes, OK?
And, we're going to
talk about the way
that this border routing
protocol actually
works in the Internet
in recitation.
But you can see
that what we've done
is we've accomplished
this sort of hierarchy
so we can make this
system, you can
make these tables much smaller
by including these star
entries in them.
It's worth just mentioning
as a final caveat
that we have given up
something for doing this.
OK, what we've done is we've
forced every node that's
within one of these regions.
Now, this node's address,
in order for this node 1.A
to be able to
continue to operate,
it can only be
connected to somebody
like C who can advertise
information about all the nodes
whose names begin with one.
So, we've basically forced this
sort of network to have this.
By imposing this
kind of a hierarchy
on the network we've limited,
to some extent, the ability
of these nodes to move between
networks because node A can
only be advertised
by way of node C.
So in the Internet
today, there's
actually multiple
layers of hierarchy.
So you may have noticed
that Internet IP addresses
have the form A.B.C.D.
So, it's a four layer
hierarchy that we
have in the Internet.
You guys will learn more about
this on Thursday in recitation.
And what we'll do
next time is talk
about the end-to-end
layer, and eliminating
some of the limitations of
the best effort network.